MANO MARKS: Hi.
This is Mano Marks.
This is the third episode in a
miniseries designed to show
you how to get started with the
Google Maps SDK for iOS.
In this episode, we'll walk
through creating a map in your
default view controller.
This builds on the first two
episodes, which showed you how
to set up your development
environment and add the
framework to your application.
Let's take a look at the
ViewController.m file.
First, you import Google Maps.
Then you create a map view
in the Load View method.
Create a GMSCameraPosition
object with the latitude,
longitude, and zoom level.
This is the initial position
that the map will view when it
is created.
Now, make the map view object
with the camera position
you've just created.
Turn on the My Location, which
creates the blue dot that the
application uses to show the
device's current location.
And then finally,
create a marker.
In this case, you're going to
create one at the same center
camera position that
you used earlier.
Give it a try.
Run the simulator.
The first time it runs, it'll
ask if the application can use
your location.
Then you should see a map
centered in Sydney, Australia,
with a marker on it that, when
you click on it, it creates an
info window with Sydney
and Australia in it.
All right.
That's it.
You've created your first map
in your application, and
you're ready to go.